salut aujourd'hui on va parler de divers
syndrome des syndromes qui vont
probablement vous étonner et donc pour
la plupart vous ne connaissez pas
l'existence des syndromes tels que ne
pas vouloir sortir de chez soi se rendre
volontairement malades avoir une peau
élastique leurs fans qui me sort c'est
dégueulasse autant de syndrome très
étrange tout aussi étranges les uns que
les autres mais avant de commencer
sachez que cette vidéo est en
partenariat avec ole m'a décelé malaurie
qui juge les bottes du premier degré
très
haut les mains c'est quoi je descend à
la cave
où les mains c'est un jeu de société qui
d'à o lui aussi en temps normal vous
déclenchez des syndromes un peu étrange
le syndrome dit par exemple du c'est
quand qu'on me réjouis parce que c'était
vraiment très cool vous en dit plus dans
quelques instants je vous partage donc
aujourd'hui une série de dix syndrome
surprenant c'est parti loïc g mary beth
le
[Applaudissements]
numéro un le syndrome dit de witsel ce
sac drame plus facile à écrire qu'à dire
vous allez peut-être penser à quelqu'un
que vous allez entendre salah personnes
atteintes de ce syndrome peut avoir
tendance à raconter des blagues
inappropriés ou à faire beaucoup trop de
jeux de mots c'est un prêt syndrome 1 on
pourrait penser que c'est pas vraiment
grave comme troubles il ya quand même
d'autres symptômes associés par exemple
la personne se permet aussi de tenir des
propos sexuels déplacés dans des
situations aussi vraiment genre pas du
tout moment et c'est un symptôme qui
s'appelle l'hypersexualité là pour le
coup ça devient un peu gênant surtout
quand ces personnes là n'ont pas du tout
conscience qu'elles ont un comportement
chelou des experts parce qu'il ya des
six peur pour toi par brigitte et des
experts qui ont constaté que les
personnes atteintes de ce trouble
peuvent avoir des lésions du lobe
frontal des tumeurs ou peuvent même être
victimes d'avc c'est le cas pour un
homme de 56 ans hospitalisé pour des
symptômes correspondant à un avc ils
arrivent à l'hôpital était vraiment très
euphoriques et tout c'est plein de jeux
de mots des petits calembours ils
avaient des comportements déplacés
envers la gente féminine les infirmières
par exemple la famille du patient
affirme pourtant qu'il ne se comportait
pas de cette façon avant son avc est
effectivement des lésions au cerveau ont
été constatés donc c'est pas vraiment de
sa faute enfin c'est pas du tout ça vous
verrez que plusieurs syndrome de la
vidéo sont dus à des avc qui créent des
dérèglements en fait dans le cerveau
mais ce n'est pas le cas de notre
deuxième syndrome qui peut être
provoquée par l'environnement et qui est
d'actualité en période de déconfinement
bon là on est plutôt bien des conflits
le syndrome de la cabane est ce que vous
avez vu comme moi ce questionnement à la
fin du confinement de vous demander
comment ça les aide de reprendre la vie
normale à l'extérieur est ce qu'on sera
ok pour croiser les gens tout ça pas
cette question représente une phobie
pour ceux qui ont le syndrome de la
cabane sont des gens qui n'osent pas
sortir de chez eux à cause des nombreux
compliments que nous on a vécu il ya
certaines personnes qui ont
malheureusement développer ce syndrome
là et en gros le temps d'enfermement a
été tellement long que la personne s'est
attaché à cent lieues d'en faire un
moment jusqu'à ne plus vouloir en sortir
en gros c'est devenu sa zone de confort
s'asseyent zone d'après viola show and
et une psychologue clinicienne avant les
confinements ces personnes ne pouvaient
avoir une légère timidité ou alors
peut-être quelques difficultés sociales
mais à cause de l'enfermement et du
changement soudain toujours un moment de
conditions de vie les aurais a peu à peu
développé le syndrome de la cabane parce
qu'ils avaient un terrain propice à ça
en fait on l'appelle aussi le syndrome
de l'escargot ou syndrome du prisonnier
l'escargot parce qu'il quitte jamais sa
maison mais bon il déplacé le prisonnier
puisqu'il est régulièrement constatée
chez les détenus après des années des
années d'enfermement à syndrome de la
kabbale ces derniers se seraient
acclimaté à ce mode de vie dans un lieu
devenu cette zone une zone de confort il
aurait alors des difficultés à sortir et
à s'adapter de nouveau au monde
extérieur avec les contraintes avec les
choses d'un confort et puis l'insécurité
aussi les personnes qui sont atteintes
du syndrome de la cabane voit le monde
extérieur et les autres comme une menace
potentielle et le problème c'est que
plus on évite une situation plus le
stress valeur s'accentuer si ce trouble
vous parlez que vous ressentez de
l'anxiété à sortir de chez vous faites
vous aider et ne laissez pas cette peur
vous emprisonner c'est très important
communiquer ça parler avec des gens et
chercher de l'aide je crois le syndrome
de même chose c'est trop dur à dire
alors qu'est ce qui se cache derrière ce
nom pas sympa a prononcé ce qui se passe
pour les personnes atteintes de ce
trouble c'est qu'elle va prétendre être
malade alors qu'elle ne l'est pas alors
attention c'est pas de la mythologie
c'est pas une personne qui est hyper
conde rilhac ça c'est ce qu'ils ont de
peur panique d'être malade a contrario
les personnes qui sont atteintes du
syndrome de munchausen s'invente des
maladies et peuvent faire en sorte de se
rendre volontairement malades vois le
truc par exemple en mangeant quelque
chose qu'il ne faut pas où en se
mutilant ou en s'exposant un risque
infectieux dans le but développer les
vrais symptômes et de justifier leur
visite médicale la grande question c'est
pourquoi est ce qu'ils font ça en fait
ces personnes ressentent un besoin un
contrôle et que le corps médical et
leurs proches leur apporte une attention
particulière cette même attention
particulière qu'on a envers un malade il
existe même le syndrome de munchausen
par procuration est là pour le coup
c'est beaucoup plus grave c'est souvent
le cas pour les mères qui affirment que
leur enfant est malade et c'est parfois
elle-même qui rendent leurs enfants
souffrent je veux dire physiquement
souffrent très grave c'est ce qui arrive
est une femme nommée delphine sa mère
falsifié ses analyses médicales
l'emmener de médecins médecins pour leur
prouver qu'elle avait un problème morin
il n'y avait rien mais il ya des
médecins qui était tellement convaincu y
manipulé par la mère de delphine qu'ils
ont procédé à de multiples opérations
jusqu'à lui retirer son rein pour rien
ce syndrome est pas mal exploités dans
les films notamment dans un film assez
populaire que vous connaissez sûrement
sixième sens mais au fait du coup c'est
quoi les syndromes du c'est quand qu'on
y rejoue parce que en fait c'était trop
cool rappelez-vous le partenariat tout
ça je le décris vite fait c'est
simplement ce qui se passe quand on
découvre le jeu haut les mains non ne
levait pas les matches et vous non plus
ne fait pas comme loïc c'est toujours
que le nom du jeu haut les mains c'est à
la basse et une application mobile que
vous connaissez d'ailleurs déjà
peut-être parce que ça a cartonné et qui
s'est depuis la rentrée de septembre
transformant en jeu de société en fait
aux les mains c'est l'histoire de six
potes qui ont créé un jeu pour adultes
qui veulent juste se marrer qu'il
faisait marrer eux afin d'en faire
profiter tout le monde pourrait être
minime du champ de limitation tout ce
qui peut faire marrer pour faire deviner
un mot une expression ou le nom d'une
personnalité c'est un super moment avec
les potes la famille règle très simple
en quelques secondes c'est près tout le
monde sait jouer et bout on y joue ça se
joue même à deux joueurs ça c'est stylé
c'est assez rare pour le jeu comme ça
jusqu'à carrément 16 joueurs qui est
quand même très pratique tu connais toi
des jeux fanny qui se joue à 16 joueurs
non ben moi non plus mais voilà et bien
là on en a quatre le syndrome de crewe
tard c'est de se prendre pour un rat
dans harry potter puis sinon il ya le
syndrome de coat ar alors celui là je
vous préviens tout de suite cela avoir
du mal à vous projetez vous avez déjà eu
la sensation d'être un mort vivant
cette impression que votre corps est
vide et que vous n'êtes plus là et bien
il y en a qui vivent ce phénomène en
continu et ça va encore plus loin parce
qu'il pense sincèrement que leurs
organes sont morts c'est un syndrome
super rare très méconnu ou la personne
un sentiment d'immortalité va se
persuader que ses organes en pourri
qu'ils ont disparu la personne dont elle
pensait à mort vivant qui n'est pas
encore passée de l'autre côté et je me
dis quand ils ont des besoins physiques
genre allez faire popo tu le sais que là
ça a fonctionné et ben non richard chase
un tueur en série américain qui a été
aussi surnommé le vampire de sacramento
était atteint de ce syndrome et se
plaignait que son coeur s'était arrêté
de battre et pour permettre à son coeur
de continuer à battre les ddt est
convaincu qu'il fallait qu'il mange des
animaux cru c'est ce qu'il faisait un
autre cas tout aussi troublant c'est
celui d'une femme de 46 ans qui avait
l'impression d'être dans un corps sans
contenu sans cerveau sans intestins sans
rial pour ce même que son corps était
translucide et c'est d'ailleurs pour ça
qu'il ne prenait pas de bains ou douche
parce qu'elle avait peur d'être soluble
et de disparaître dans le siphon tonnes
+ cachet d'aspirine la paix on sourit
mais c'est chaud quand tu vis à ce
syndrome grave peut apparaître dans le
cadre d'une dépression ou encore d'une
schizophrénie par exemple 5 le syndrome
de diogène howard pug est ce que vous
connaissez c'est un producteur américain
qui a notamment produit le film scarface
il était atteint du syndrome de diogène
un syndrome compliqué à vivre surtout
pour les proches que vous avez vraiment
comprendre pourquoi il s'agit en fait
d'un syndrome qui pousse la personne a
accumulé un tas d'objets des bains
partout mais pas seulement la personne
tant à se négliger complètement
elle-même et à s'isoler en général la
personne habite donc dans un
environnement très sale avec des
détritus des vieux journaux de la
vaisselle sale et parfois même s'il
arrive ses propres excréments l'ajout de
la livre du coup c'est compliqué non
seulement pour la famille mais aussi et
surtout pour les voisins qui doivent
supporter les odeurs et puis les
potentiels animaux et insectes nuisibles
qui rapplique forcément dans l'immeuble
parce que c'est super pros ils sont
contents quoi le docteur laurence
hugonnot qu'il ne pesait que j'ai riad
raconte qu'un de ses patientes possède
trois appartements une maison et une
boutique que tout est plat et qui ne
peut même plus rentrer dans aucun de ses
locaux du coup il est à la rue vraiment
comme un sdf et c'est fou mais faut se
dire qu'il pas jeter c'est compliqué ils
peuvent avoir une pile de toutes les
boîtes de camembert qu'ils ont acheté
pour manger du camembert durant vingt
ans c'est ok pour eux quoi c'est un
trouble qui arrivent la plupart du temps
à la suite d'un traumatisme quand même
c'est pas patiné comme ça spontanée à
noter que ça touche en majorité des
personnes âgées et plus particulièrement
les femmes je syndrome d'excitation
sexuelle
si vous êtes un être humain comme moi
vous aimez certainement prendre du
plaisir en amour quand je dis du plaisir
je parle d'orgasme j'hésitais à dire le
mot pour la censure mais bon la chaîne
est un peu chad bad en ce moment donc
c'est le plus ça de moins alors le plus
performant d'entre nous en ont déjà
peut-être eu cinq en une journée mais
qu'est ce que vous penseriez d'en avoir
50 par jour ça en faire un toutes les 30
minutes en moyenne eh bien c'est ce que
vivent les victimes de ce syndrome et
oui c'est bien des victimes
malheureusement à ce niveau on n'est
plus dans du plaisir pour eux aussi
reconduit alors plusieurs choses à
savoir déjà ça concerne uniquement les
femmes et les leurs orgasmes aux moments
d'intense plaisir peuvent provenir de
toutes les zones érogènes du corps
humain en vrai c'est invivable kim
ramsay une américaine a vécu des
orgasmes successifs après avoir fait une
chute dans un escalier chute qui aurait
déclenché son syndrome et c'est
tellement dur à vivre que certaines
femmes en viennent au suicide c'est
arrivé comme greenstein mot la naine qui
a eu près de 50 orgasmes par jour
pendant 16 ans à raison donc dans toutes
les 30 minutes c'est invivable alors
c'est quoi les autres causes apparemment
ça sera en lien avec les hormones
puisque les femmes qui en sont victimes
sont principalement grande majorité en
période de péri ménopause et autour de
la ménopause quoi mais cela peut aussi
concerner les femmes qui ont des varices
génitales ou une hyperactivité de la
vessie syndrome de la main étrangère
notre prochain syndrome vous le
connaissez peut-être on en a déjà parlé
ici sur la chaîne mais ça peut vous
servir d'alibi pour faire absolument
n'importe quoi donc route mais bien son
nom c'est le syndrome de la main
étrangère c'est pas vous c'est la main
étrangère aurait quand je suis tombé
dessus j'ai halluciné et je m'étais dit
que ça ça me rendrait complètement fou à
vivre mais vraiment ça me fait
extrêmement peur imaginez vous êtes en
train d'enfiler votre pantalon avec
votre main gauche et votre main droite
tente de le baisser vraiment c'est ce
qui arrive est un homme de 45 ans
atteint du syndrome de la main étrangère
sa main droite celle inverse de sa main
gauche et inversement
et ce de façon incontrôlable mais celle
inverse dans les intentions un jour par
exemple alors que cet homme était en
train de conduire sa voiture il a voulu
tourner le volant avec sa main gauche et
sa main droite après le ballon pour l'en
empêcher les tournadre encore plus
étonnant lorsque cet homme s'est promené
dans la rue et qu'il a voulu tourner à
gauche et que ça ma droite a attrapé un
poteau pour l'empêcher de tourner à
gauche pendant plusieurs minutes l'homme
est resté bloqué jusqu'à ce que sa maman
décide de lâcher le poteau c'est un peu
vous savez dans fight club quand quand
la fin on voit que tyler etc et qui on
doit se mettre des patates tout seul bon
ben là c'est pas un dédoublement de
personnalité c'est juste la main qui
décident de ce qu'elle fait vraiment il
ya un côté cartoon à ça mais pourtant
c'est la réalité et c'est pas
cartoonesque aviv dans la plupart des
cas c'est la main droite qui obéit à son
propriétaire et la main gauche qui est
on appelle la menthe désobéissante ce
qui se passe dans le cerveau c'est que
la communication entre les deux
hémisphères cérébraux et altérer ce
syndrome peut se déclarer après une
attaque cérébrale ou tumeurs une
intervention chirurgicale ou simplement
à cause de la maladie d'alzheimer et
encore c'est une liste non exhaustive on
va revenir sur un truc plus léger un
pull marron d'un peu ouvre quand même
c'est le syndrome des cheveux en
coiffant alors là je vous vois tous
venir dans les commentaires en me disant
que vous vous reconnaissez ou que vous
me reconnaissais mais c'est sûrement
pire que ce que vous vous imaginez si
loïc était encore derrière la caméra on
dirait que c'est tiré par les disons que
ça va un peu plus loin que des petits
epide mèche rebelle le matin au réveil
la personnes atteintes de ce syndrome a
des cheveux couleur blond dressés sur la
tête sans la possibilité de les aplatir
très bizarre c'est le cas pour cette
jeune fille que vous venez de voir sur
l'image une jeune australienne atteintes
de ce syndrome alors extrêmement rare
évidemment pour permettre à leurs filles
d accepter sa différence est de gagner
confiance en elle ses parents ont créé
un compte un stade qui rassemble
aujourd'hui et beaucoup de monde c'est
plus de 16 mille abonnés des résultats
qui ont été publiés dans l'american
journal of human genetics explique que
la maladie se réduit à dix mutation
récit cible de trois gènes impliqués
dans la formation du cheveu donc c'est
un bug mais bonne nouvelle si ce
syndrome apparaît en général entre 3
mois et de 12 ans alors il disparaît
ensuite à la puberté syndrome
d'ehlers-danlos on a tous eu ce genre de
potes au collège hyper souple à la gym
ça raconte un peu eh bien il ya des gens
qui en souffrent j'ai bien dit qu' on
souffre vous allez comprendre pourquoi
si une personne est atteinte du syndrome
d'ehlers-danlos elle va avoir une
souplesse anormale des articulations des
vaisseaux sanguins fragile ainsi qu'une
peau très élastique c'est ce dont
souffre la mannequin sa rage hearts si
on peut utiliser le mot souffre parce
que en fait à main n'a fait plutôt une
force elle en l'assumant complètement ce
syndrome qui touche cinq mille personnes
dans le monde est dû à un défaut de
production de collagène de la collagène
une protéine qui donne l'élasticité à
l'ap otan dont les gourmands et parfois
aux organes et aux vaisseaux sanguins
mais du coup le problème va au delà du
physique compris puisque le corps est
beaucoup plus fragile que la normale et
on peut constater des saignements
régulièrement par exemple lorsque la
personne se brosse les dents puisque les
gencives sont très minces à part ça va
signer beaucoup en bref t'es un peu
obligé de faire attention à tout ce que
tu fais pour pas te blesser c'est un
vrai problème c'est un peu galère au
quotidien parce que tu es toujours en
train de faire gaffe le syndrome de la
belle au bois dormant est ce que vous
aimeriez dormir un genre tout le temps
bien au chaud au lit pepy c'est ce que
vit charic tovar une jeune femme qui
atteinte du syndrome de kleine 20
syndrome de la belle au bois dormant et
c'est pas génial en réalité cette
maladie est plutôt handicapante au
quotidien puisqu'elle oblige la personne
à dormir pendant des semaines comme une
hibernation genre charic tovar qui est
victime d'hypersomnie vie des phases de
sommeil très longue dans l'une d'entre
elles a duré deux mois c'est énorme la
personnes atteintes de ce trouble peut
dormir jusqu'à 23 heures par jour même
mon chat il est un peu plus réveillé
comme beaucoup c'est à peine si elle
peut manger et boire et puis quand elle
se réveille c'est pas comme si elle
était en mode ou là j'ai bien dormi je
suis en forme non charic par exemple
avait complètement désorientée elle est
confuse à la des pertes de mémoire et
elle a même déjà perdu connaissance
après en se réveillant pour vous dire à
quel point ça va loin elle a même oublié
le visage de sa mère ce qui est
compliqué c'est que les causes sont
encore inconnues comme souvent pour les
maladies très rares l'étude qui a été
publiée dans le journal pediatrics
neurology brics qui suggère qu'un
pathogènes pourrait affecter
l'hypothalamus du malade la zone qu'ils
contrôlent la fin le stress ou l'éveil
j'espère que vous derrière l'écran vous
êtes resté réveiller tout au long de la
vidéo gérant ou de la sphère file j'ai
pas parlé trop vite c'est pas que ça
vous a appris des choses si ce format
vous a plu vous me le dit un deuxième tu
connais débat xterra faut que ça fasse
au moins 250 émue pour peu on s'est
revus pour un épisode 2 dit mon
commentaire le syndrome vous qui vous a
le plus surpris moi je je sais pas
encore j'hésite encore merci aussi
encore à haut les mains d'avoir
sponsoriser la vidéo ainsi que je vous
intéresse n'hésitez pas à découvrir
davantage va via via un virage bien que
je vais vous mettre dans la description
de la vidéo jeux mais aussi deux autres
épisodes des deux derniers qui sont
sortis à peu près dans le même état
d'esprit et puis je vous dis alors on
est quand aujourd'hui je sais que si
vous voyez cette vidéo un vendredi vous
dira lundi si vous voyez cette vidéo
lundi à vendredi prenez soin de vous
mais le short il vient de bien soin ça
fait plaisir à très bientôt ici dans les
salles de spectacle regardez c'est la
femme de tournée après les spectacles
ces termes si vous voulez réserver bien
dans la description j'en parlerai plus
énormément mais c'est maintenant que ça
se joue zénith de paris tous hâte au
multi c'est à très bientôt bisous